- [Instructor] When you hear
constant of proportionality,
it can seem a little bit
intimidating at first.
It seems very technical.
But as we'll see, it's a
fairly intuitive concept,
and we'll do several
examples and hopefully
you'll get a lot more comfortable with it.
So let's say we're trying to
make some type of baked goods,
maybe it's some type of muffin,
and we know that depending
on how many muffins
we're trying to make,
that for a given number of eggs,
we always want twice as many cups of milk.
So we could say cups of milk,
cups of milk, that's going to be equal to
two times the number of eggs.
So what do you think the constant
of proportionality is here,
sometimes known as the
proportionality constant?
Well yes, it is going to be two.
This is a proportional relationship
between the cups of milk
and the number of eggs.
The cups of milk are always
going to be two times
the number of eggs.
Give me the number of eggs,
I'm going to multiply it
by the constant of proportionality
to get the cups of milk.
And we can see how this is
a proportional relationship
a little bit clearer if we set up a table.
So if we say number of eggs
and if we say cups of milk
and make a table here,
well if you have one egg,
how many cups of milk
are you gonna have?
Well this right over here
would be one times two,
well you're gonna have two cups of milk.
If you had three eggs, well
you're just gonna multiply
that by two to get your cups of milk,
so you're gonna have six cups of milk.
If you had 1,000,000 eggs, so
we have a very big party here,
maybe we're some sort of
industrial muffin producer,
well how many cups of milk?
Well you put 1,000,000 in right over here,
multiply it by two, you
get your cups of milk.
You're going to need
2,000,000 cups of milk.
And you can see that this is
a proportional relationship.
To go from number of eggs to cups of milk,
we indeed multiplied by two every time.
That came straight from this equation.
And you could also see,
look whenever you multiply
your number of eggs by a certain amount,
you're multiplying your cups
of milk by the same amount.
If I multiply my eggs by 1,000,000,
I'm multiplying my cups
of milk by 1,000,000.
So this is clearly a
proportional relationship.
Let's get a little bit
more practice identifying
the constant of proportionality.
So let's say I'll make it
a little bit more abstract,
let's say I have some variable a
and it is equal to five
times some variable b.
What is the constant of
proportionality here?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
Yes, it is five.
Give me a b, I'm gonna
multiply it by five,
and I can figure out what a needs to be.
Let's do another example.
If I said that y is equal to
pi times x, what is the constant
of proportionality here?
Well you give me an x, I'm gonna
multiply it times a number,
the number here is pi, to give you y.
So our constant of
proportionality here is pi.
Let's do one more.
If I were to say
that y is equal to 1/2 times x,
what is the constant of proportionality?
Pause this video.
Think about it.
Well once again, this is
just going to be the number
that we're multiplying
by x to figure out y.
So it is going to be 1/2.
In general, you might sometimes
see it written like this.
y is equal to k times x,
where k would be some
constant that would be
our constant of proportionality.
You see 1/2 is equal to k here,
pi is equal to k right over there.
So hopefully that helps.